finance we continue with president
Trump's attorney former New York City
Mayor Rudy Giuliani I want to clarify
something cuz I was asking you about
Perkins cuy and you said the money was
not campaign money I'm giving you a fact
now that you don't know it's not
campaign money no campaign violation and
I said because they funneled through a
law firm where I think we're we were
talking about two different things there
I want to make up I was talking about
the hundred thirty thousand dollar
payment right the settlement payment
which is a very regular thing for
lawyers to do question there was the
only possible violation there would be
was it a campaign finance violation but
usually would result in a fine by the
way not this big storm of storm troopers
coming in and breaking down his
apartment and breaking out his office
that was money that was paid by by his
lawyer the way I would do out of his law
firm funds or whatever funds doesn't
matter the president reimbursed that
over a period of seven he it said didn't
I distinctly remember that he did it on
his own he did without asking look I
don't know I haven't investigated that
no reason to dispute that no reason
industry with recollection I like
Michael a lot you like Michael a long
time I feel very bad he's been
victimized like this the president feels
even worse the fact is just trust me
they're going to come up with no
violations there all right be meaning
the yeah they wrote it perfectly legal
let me go back to the main crux of all
document it let me go back to the main
crux the crux says that we have a
two-tier justice system the president's
right when he says witch-hunt yeah sure
you can't explain this any other way
first of all they never should have an
investigation there was no Russian
collusion we're now a year and a half
two years into this no Russian collusion
case over in falling all over themselves
to investigate him they have committed
numerous violations including lies which
was a criminal deception outrageous
search warrants like the one on on Cohn
how about we go back to Manta for
breaking into his house
2005 nothing to do with working a drug
dealer or is it crazy he was a Richard
wasn't a violent criminal is a sensor I
I go is this I was they did to man
afford I used to do to the Mafia not not
not drug dealers and mafia members and
killers how is this how do you see this
ending and you've talked to you've
talked to Molly no I you know they're
gonna write a report
they cannot untie them I don't believe
they can subpoena him they are gonna
have to write a report
if we don't be interviewed or if we do
get interviewed they'll write the report
based on the interview they won't write
it before by Hilary guy because he's not
a special person
he's just entrusted with the safety of
the world this election in 2018 gonna be
a referendum on Donald Trump yeah words
right we go to the American people and
say the following real quick you want to
vote for impeachment but you want to
impeach the president they're not gonna
want to you want to have Nancy Pelosi
running running the house House of
Representatives forget it mr. mayor
thank you for being gone always good to
see you you're a patriot thank you sir